you might already have some type of a
notion of what a cell is you might
already realize that it is the most
basic
unit of life some would argue that maybe
viruses are even a more basic unit of
life but the organisms that we consider
living like ourselves are made up of
cells and all living organisms that we
for sure consider living are made up of
at least one cell so most basic unit of
life for example me this thing that's
making a video right now i'm made up of
tens of trillions of these cells
now a common misconception is well these
things must be small and they indeed are
very very very small some cells are on
the order of one micrometer long and a
micrometer is one millionth of a meter
or you could say one thousandth of a
millimeter and so when you think of
something that small sometimes there's
an assumption that it must be simple
but you could not be more wrong if you
assume that a cell is simple
this right over here is a picture of a
budding yeast cell you can see that it's
budding off right over here but this
just begins to show you some of the
complexity of the cell itself or of any
cell and we're in other videos we're
going to talk about different types of
cells different types of structures
you'll see in some cells versus others
this right over here is a eukaryotic
cell which we will talk more about in
other videos now all cells have a
membrane that separate it from the
outside world you see the membrane right
over here this is just a cross section
you could imagine a three dimensional
version of this so this is the cell
cell
membrane kind of defines the cell in
some way and in general the things
inside the cell membrane is considered
the cytoplasm
cytoplasm sometimes you will hear the
term cytosol the cytoplasm includes not
just the fluid but also all the stuff in
the fluid while the cytosol is referring
to the fluid alone and then depending on
the complexity of a cell so this is
right here this yeast cell this is a
eukaryotic cell which we will cover in
more depth in other videos but one of
the features of a eukaryotic cell is
that you will have a membrane-bound
nucleus now you see it in this diagram
right over here this is not a common
feature to all cells but the only reason
why i'm mentioning it in this video is
officially the cytoplasm does not
include the stuff inside the nucleus in
a eukaryotic cell that is called the
nucleoplasm but we'll talk more about
that in other videos now another feature
that is common to all cells is the
notion of a ribosome
and this picture is full of ribosomes
all these little dots right here these
little red dots let me change my pen
color all these little red dots here
these are ribosomes and you might assume
wow these are so small compared to this
already small thing this cell surely
they are simple but they're actually
fairly complex
rna and protein structures that are
their main function is producing protein
producing
protein you could view these as almost
the protein factories of living
organisms they can take genetic
information in the form of rna and
produce proteins out of them and you can
see this cell is full of ribosomes and
we're going to talk about different
types of ribosomes in a future video now
another thing that is typical in most
cells is genetic information and
typically that genetic information is
stored as
dna
now i say in most cells because it turns
out that even in our own bodies mature
red blood cells don't have any dna
anymore and there's other cells that do
the same thing but in general in order
for a cell to function and replicate it
needs some genetic information and that
is stored in dna
that's true in both prokaryotic cells
and eukaryotic cells prokaryotes are
ones that don't have a well-defined
nucleus and membrane-bound what we call
organelles which are these substructures
and cells which we will talk more about
in other videos in a prokaryotic cell
the dna is just floating around in the
cytoplasm while in the eukaryotic cell
the dna for the most part is inside of
your nucleus and it is part of the
nucleoplasm
so i'll leave you there for now the last
thing i want you to appreciate is just
the scale as i mentioned cells are small
this picture of a yeast cell right over
here this is a micrometer on this scale
it would be about
would be about that that would be one
micrometer and to put that in context
the width of a human hair and it
actually depends on your hair whether
it's soft or there's more like my hair
and it kind of sticks up and it's you
have thicker hair but if this is a human
hair right over here this is it's this
is a width of a human hair this thing
its width is anywhere from 20 to
180 micrometers my thick hair is
probably closer to the 180 micrometers
so one way to think about it you could
probably take 20 or so of these yi cells
end to end and these e cells these
aren't even the small cells by any
stretch of the imagination and put them
end to end 20 or 30 of these across one
human hair and that's what's
mind-blowing because even at that scale
you have this complexity and even this
picture doesn't do proper justice to the
complexity there's all sorts of
structures inside of this that you can't
even see that help transport things and
move things around
and give the structure of the cell
so i'll leave you there in future videos
we'll dig a little bit more into what
eukaryotic cells are what prokaryotic
cells are how do cells move around how
do they work together